Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's try Fred from
Germany. Fred from Germany. You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Oh, great, I'm a big fan of your show has been
oh, I'm a little nervous, but I've been I've
been a listener for about a year. Oh, great.
I want to ask a question about about. Yeah, I have
an economic question, and you talked a lot about
the debt and deficit. Yes. And I'd like
to know you just interviewed someone who
wrote a book about it post Growth Economy.
And my question about that would be,
if you are in favor of sort of post capitalist
post growth ideas and I don't see that you
are. That's like a general you shouldn't you be
worried about. Debt and deficit in the way that
if you're increasing the debt or the deficit
and a high magnitude, you're sort of creating
a need for more economic growth, because
if you if the debt grows much faster
than the economy, then that's bad, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this really would be
a question for someone who is actually
like a post growth or because that I'm I,
I don't know that I'm a post growth or I think
there is obviously some physical limit to the
resources of the planet. And at some point that
will become a factor. But there's really two
points of view on your question. Right? One
is, well, if we want to go to post growth,
part of the reason we need growth is because we
continually have more debt. So we need the growth
in order to pay for the debt. That would be one
view. So that would be the more debt there is,
the more the longer we're locked into needing the
growth. That's one view, but there's another view
as well. And the other view would be if eventually
this is all a house of cards that will implode
because we will reach the limit of resources for
the country, for the planet, rather then these
financial ledgers on which we have debt are sort
of irrelevant. Either we get to a point where
it doesn't matter or the planet collapses and
therefore who cares about debt and deficits. So I
don't you know, it would be more of a question for
somebody who's really an ideologue in that I don't
say that in in a negative way, but an ideologist
in that space. But it seems to me you could really
make the argument on both sides of that question.
Speaker 2: OK. Thanks for your answer and yeah,
thank you for answering my question.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thanks for a.
All right, Fred from Germany,
very specific question, I like it.